so I'll show something that happened in
one of my games I played in the Bliss
tournament on Saturday so this was my
first run game and I'm gonna say who it
was against but I think this is the
common mistake that happens in a lot of
players games so we started normal
Bishop c4 playing Italian so so far
everything's normal
nothing out of the ordinary and then my
opponent played h6 so what is wrong with
this move yeah and
a six is not a weakness so so why is it
better to play this move right out of
the opening now I understand you're
providing 95 but first of all I in this
position I'm not threatening 95 so so a
six is a prophylactic move in general
what's a prophylactic move
yeah a preventative move but in this
position I'm not really threatening
anything so you don't need to do that so
what are the things that you're supposed
to be doing in opening here three things
develop and fight for the center and
castle
so h6 does neither one of those things
therefore it's a bad move so you're not
you're not developing your pieces you're
not getting close to counseling and
you're not doing anything in the center
so in generally in the opening we don't
want to play with our side pawns so if
we go back one move so why is this move
okay here it's again it's a side pawn
it's not developing a piece it's not
fighting for the center so why is it
okay to make this move here Yeah right
it's a temple move the temple move is a
move that attacks something so captures
checks mates raised is our old temple
moves so since in this position h6
doesn't do any of those things we can
say it's not a good move so next what
happened is okay so what's the move that
you should be doing here two moves so
what are the developing moves here yeah
right okay so if you don't want to deal
with nine-to-five you want to play
Bishop c5 because it because there is no
95 the queen is open and this is
something that happens a lot of my a lot
of my students sue and I told them every
time and every time they make the same
mistakes so Bishop c5 so you're
developing the piece you're putting it
on a nice square I meant ever didn't
work okay
you're controlling a central square so
everything's good okay so actually let's
go over detailin because italian is
something that everyone faces right does
everyone play this overhead this happens
all the time and they're so realize that
you have to know and actually I played
the Italian with white a lot too and not
a lot of people do because it's not like
in a higher level especially if you look
at it doesn't happen at all because a
lot of people don't think of it as a
very challenging opening but personally
I like it so why please c3 so what's the
threat of c3 we're still enough opening
free so where is why trying to do one of
the three things right it's not
preventing your playing white so you're
not you don't have to prevent your
attacking so you want to play d4 you
want to grab the center so what's a good
move for black it's important to
understand the moves not just make them
because if there is not preventing
anything sin 3 is for a simple purpose
of pushing t4 and grabbing the whole
center so if you play a move like Knight
e7 or h6 then I'm just going to go t4
and now I have the whole center and why
is it bad to lose the center my too bad
for your opponent control the whole
center
I don't make such a big deal out of it
right
especially the Knights right if you put
a knight in the center of the board
attacks eight squares if you put a
knight in the edge of the board attacks
like 3/4 depends we're on the edge so
when you put your pieces in the squares
there are more attack more squares and
there are more active which means
they're doing more and if you're doing
more and you're attacking the center
that means your opponent has less space
if you have less space and you have less
squares for your pieces your pieces are
not attacking they're defending so you
don't want to right away from the
opening get into such a defensive
position that like I take over the whole
center I take over the whole center my
bishops good my pieces are out and I
assume you're gonna start running out of
squares so let's say you play here and I
play here knight on you have to find it
square for this night
so starting move eight right away you
don't want to get into bad defensive
position so I don't think it's very good
idea for beginning to learn a lot of
openings and you know like read all this
theory but I think you should know the
basics and just understand the reason
behind your moves a lot of people just
play the moves and they learn it they
memorize it and they blitz out the moves
and they know I have no idea why they're
doing it so your focus should be
understanding your ideas and so far
we're not doing anything complex so
citrate threatening t4 so what should
black do
we need to castle so was appears an easy
command the knight Knight f6 so what's
good about this remove with those two
things right so it's a temple move
you're attacking upon and you're getting
close to castling so now you're one move
away from castling so here white has two
options even to either to defend the
pawn or push d4 so this is a line that
it's an important line because it's
forced so they form so what to do take
or move the bishop take right okay so
now we're to move the bishop
there's only one person saying every
someone else would say something why be
six
so if remember it's always better to do
things with a temple because when you
make a temple move it's like you're
getting a free move so if you check your
opponent your opponent has to do
something and then it's your turn again
if you could Bishop b6 now it's my turn
and now I have an option to do whatever
I wanted and I can put my central pawns
or I can just develop and now again I'm
controlling the whole center and you
can't because all the central squares
under my control and now you don't have
as much spaces for your pieces you
should be four checked so White has the
White has two ways of playing guitar
Bishop d2 Knight c3 so ninety-two knight
Knight c3 is a pawn sacrifice so now you
can grab the pawn so let's all Castle
tonight I'm out of the pin so now how to
continue so we take the second pump
okay so how to continue
what
uh-huh
and then I take all right so you can do
that or how can you fix your knight in
the center how do we make sure that
night stays here it's a good movie to
tag something it defines your night and
it's a central move c5 you think three
things at once you're opening your
Bishop you're attacking your opponent's
piece you defend your knight
so what's wrong with this move this move
loses yeah double-check your last wish
your knight so we're gonna move ten so
you definitely don't want to do it so
why is it so you took eforp on the e4
pawn and I cancelled and usually taking
this kind of funds into the interests
meant why is it dangerous in this
position right so we don't open the
center when our king is in the center an
open Center is a center that doesn't
have any pawns a closed Center is a
center that has like D 44 and is 65 all
those pawns in the center so you don't
want to do that when your king is in the
center so when your king is in the
center you know you're not going to
castle for a while you have to make sure
the center stays closed otherwise your
king is going to be in trouble
okay so what's wrong with doing this so
I grab the pawn with a ten point when I
cancel next move now I'm up two pawns so
if I'm up to Fonts an idol a castle for
one movement I can cancel the next vote
then it's fine I'll just be offered I'll
be up to funds guys yeah
Queen b3 what about your rook okay so
you're sacrificing the whole rook if
you're going to do something like this
committal you have to calculate it
otherwise you're going to end up with no
pawns and no rook okay so you took this
now I ran away okay and then if I block
I mean d5 what about this guy okay you
can do rook takes but what's the
material you're done in exchange and
what a pond
yeah a pond so now I hear I can do
artificial castle I'll kick this Bishop
out you have to move somewhere and then
I'll play here and do an outer fuel
castle or actually here I can just play
Knight a5 and take this guy so remember
when you're attacking and especially if
you're done material and attacking you
don't want to exchange pieces because
you're going to find with nothing to
attack with so okay so if you're going
to sacrifice a whole rope let's try
something else here
Bishop g5 bringing another piece and
temple move so what's blacks only moved
we don't want to lose the Queens 97 okay
so how to continue the attack
yeah so you can do rookie one the
problem rookie with rookie one is if you
take only seven and we exchange
everything I'm still going to have two
rocks for a queen and now you exchange
you're given more pieces so it's going
to be even harder to attack so let's
bring another piece into the attack so
what's the last piece does not in the
attack the knight so here you can also
take and play for compensation but 95 so
what's your threat
let's say I make a I can pass them up so
let's say I make a random move to pass
the move to white what would Y do here
right so yeah if the bishop is gone it's
funny because your bishop is getting in
your way if the bishop is gone you'll
play Queen f7 so what to do with the
bishop yeah so Bishop Jake is one option
the reason I don't like Bishop g8 is is
you're putting your bishop under attack
so whenever if I want to escape to jail
I'm also going to capture your king the
mote that I do like is Bishop g6 and the
reason is after d5 Muslim of Nam I will
check from a different angle left three
and Bishop by five now my bishop is
controlling this square so now I'm going
to take and now you're going to be in
real trouble even material wise next to
I'm going to take your Bishop and even
material wise I'm doing fine and yeah
you're getting checkmate it
yeah if you play King eat we can tell me
mate in two
right so again your Bishop is getting in
the is in your way so you want to get
rid of it again think the temple moves
if you want to do something if you can
do it by force it's always better now
your opponent has no options if you can
leave your opponent no options and you
know that's how things go your way your
opponent has options and maybe they'll
find the defense now meet so these are
the kind of things we want to avoid in
the opening you don't want to get too
greedy in the opening so you don't want
to either grab another pawn sometimes
you can there are openings like that but
your king is in the center your
opponent's pieces are out so it's very
dangerous to grab this kind of pawns so
in this position it's much better to
grab this pawn and play d5 there is
another variation that I don't really
want to go into because it's a very long
variation so okay let's just stop here
okay another way for white to block is
Bishop d2 so what happens if they take
your pawn now
well if you do that here I can play can
I castle no I can just play 27
I'm not pinned anymore so I can move my
knight so again so here here so what
kind of piece is the before night yes
exam
so Hank yeah it's a loose piece it was
because it's not defended so what's
wrong with Queen B 3 yeah
yeah so there is 27 there is also d5 so
you're not going to really do anything
so one of the most important things in
Jesse's move orders sometimes you have
an idea and it doesn't work so you
change the move order and it's a very
common common tool to use when you know
you're trying to do something and then
something's not working so you always
have to make sure your move order is
correct because you can come up with the
most brilliant idea and play the
incorrect first move and then nothing
works so how can we reverse the move
order to make Queen b3 a forced move
which takes f7 the Queen B dream so of
course I have to block and now what
right so what's wrong with just taking
right away what will your opponents do
right so it's artificial castle does I
don't know what article counseling is
that's when you cancel you don't cancel
like normally you move your King you
bring your rook and then your King goes
back and now black is fine so the knight
is on a nice square everything is fine
that's why we throw in ninety five what
kind of a move is ninety five there's a
name for it yeah it's an intermediate
move puts an intermediate move and
actually when we're doing calculations
and when we miss something in our
calculation a lot of times it's an
intermediate move because when we're
calculating a lot of times our
calculation is just straightforward line
so I think I go here my opponent goes
here I capture you captures like
capturing captures so what's an
intermediate move it's a loop that's not
it's not expected so yeah when you
capture your opponent's piece you can
expect it move is for him to capture
back but when you throw in a check or
you throw in an attack that's an
intermediate move it's something that
doesn't doesn't really follow the normal
sequence that you're expecting so you
play here now the King moves somewhere
and now you capture and now this King is
stuck here okay so let's go back so if
you're playing like that it's possible
that this can happen in your tournament
games because special kids like to play
the Italian kids on me so what to do
with plug you've given up the center so
keep that in mind your quote your one
move away from castling so your king is
safe and the reason your king is safe is
because your opponent hasn't canceled
either your opponent has castle then
you're behind but now your king is safe
so your one move away from canceling so
your job is to fight for the center so
how to do that
so we exchanged the bishops first and
the night doesn't really want to be on
t2 right the night will rather be on c3
because it does more on c3 but here he
has to capture because otherwise this is
hanging so 90 to 95 and it's very
important to play d5 here because if you
don't play the five power play three
five or d5 and then again you lost the
center so d5 and here so another
important move yeah
you're raising your hand on so your
night is under attack
can we move that night can this night
move it can but shouldn't right okay so
we need to defend it so how to defend it
eight-six
what's wrong with Bishop e6 what is my
queen doing oops oh there you go yeah so
my quaint thing to think so how else to
defend this night yes okay so we can
also go Knights see before is this a
good move right because again it's loose
its undefended so now you have two nice
there are loose and then when I attack
the defender now you're going to lose a
piece and then I don't care about this
check I'm going to move my King and now
I'm actually threatening also this now
you're all in all kinds of trouble so
here yes Knight c7 so what kind of a
pawn is this d4 pawn isolated pawn so
what do we do to isolated pawns what are
we doing to the pawn right now we're
blocking it so we want to make sure that
isolated fund doesn't move and get
traded because it's a weakness so let's
say castle castle so how is black going
to finish his development let's say I
make a move so we have to develop this
guy that's not b6
v6 is kind of loose because then if I
put pressure on your d5 Knight you don't
want to play c6 so against an isolated
punt you want to fix the isolate fun you
want to make sure it doesn't move so you
want what you want to do just to talk
briefly got my pawn structure is play C
six and now your structure is more solid
you don't want to play C six let's say
okay you don't want to play B six and
then in the future have to play C six
because now the c6 pawn is a weakness
right it's not protected by a pawn so
it's going to be weak for you so you
don't want to do that so what you want
to do is you want to put your phone on
c6 right away and then play Queen c7 or
Queen b6 and now your structure is more
together so now everything in your
position is solid and pawn structures
are very important because pawn
structures are very permanent when you
move upon it's not coming back so when
you commit your pawn to a square you
know you want to be very careful you
don't want to move your pawns unless you
know it's going to be saved
okay so we got very forced so there's
another way of playing the Italian does
I won't follow so far yeah so remember
this position so here I played d4 so
this ponent is under attack another way
to play is d3 so d6 and castle so my
question is when do we have to worry
about this Bishop g5 pin
why not so let's say I canceled its
Bishop g5 something to worry about why
not because I can't put a knight on d5
because I can attack the knight again
imagine you're playing black do you care
if - you're fine pinzhi right now in
this position sometimes no why not
of course you're not going to move your
knight and lose your queen but here it's
a problem let me ask you this let's say
I play a six and your opponent plays
here what's the difference yeah
I'm not controlling 1d 4v4 which square
be four okay but I wasn't controlling
you four here either so my question is
castle and Bishop g5 versus a6 and
Bishop g5 there's a big difference so
what difference does it make that you
haven't cancelled yet
exactly so you don't worry about this
pin before you cancelled you're not
going to do this when you're already
committed to counseling because once you
cancel and you do things like this first
of all you have to worry about your
opponent sacrificing so it's something
to worry about
second of all even if I don't sacrifice
look at your King like even your
opponent didn't do this yo can you did
this your own King and you know you
don't you don't do things like that once
you castle but if you haven't cancelled
it's actually to your advantage because
let's say I play six Bishop g5 and now
we'd say are you going to cancel the
Queen site so Bishop here this guy come
here and it's good that you push your
punt because when you cancel how is
canceling on the same side different
from opposites from canceling on the
opposite side what can you do when you
castle on the opposite side that you're
not going to do when you castle on the
same side at least not normally push
your pawns and here you already pushed
your pawns and you push your palms with
a temple so again I want to emphasize
this whole idea of doing things with the
temple you got like two moves in for
free if my bishop was still one c1 and
you were trying to do this then you
would waste the time to play 65 but here
you do it with tempest it's like you're
getting moves for free and actually in
this position a six and I want to
emphasize this move water so I'm going
to go over it again especially if you
want to play this position well this
opening part is important so Bishop c5
c3 threatening t4 so you have to play
Knight f6 your opponent defends you play
d6 protecting g5 opening up your bishop
castles a six a six is the important
move a six as a positional threat
yeah heist be five appositional do it if
I'm is very weakening if I make some
kind of a move when you play b5 you just
weaken your position remember what I
told you don't put your pawns 9595 is a
very very important threat because
what's the strongest why did I make a
move for white what Plus yeah so this
Bishop is a very important piece so if
we can get rid of it then it's going to
it's a big achievement for us and we
haven't cancelled yet but we're only one
move away from counseling and the center
is closed so it's okay listen remember
if the center was open none of this
would be okay this a 485 pounds were
gone rook e1 then you would not be happy
so white has to move the bishop
okay so um I don't know if I want to
play 26 okay so you play not oh but I
don't think I'm going to take this night
okay so even if you want to play before
then I'm going to so you have to go back
right yeah okay so let me see how I want
to do this so here I can do my
artificial castle so I can just move my
bishop and next move king gage seven and
the Rope comes out so now to several
good things happen for me so I got the
two bishops and two bishops in chess and
a lot of times our big advantage
especially when the position opens up
which means there are no pawns in the
center because bishops are very powerful
and especially can appreciate this when
you play em games with two bishops
because it just controlled or you attack
with the bishop they just control the
whole board so I have two bishops now
after I play King h7 rook f8 my rook is
going to be my rook is going to be open
on the open file
my bishop is going to come back this
other bishops going to pin you so I've
fallen a little behind but again because
the center is closed and you're not
developed yourself I can get away with
this now I had a knight on a five not a
knight here in this position now have a
knight so I don't know what King g6 I'm
taking this night maybe that's possible
but this is very scary maybe I want to
play with a king on g5 I don't think I
have a good discovery check yeah now I
don't know about this let's not do
things like that so so we don't so we
have to save our bishop so now this
bishop goes back so what's the purpose
behind a move like this
all right so I'm but I'm maintaining
there's a good thing about Bishop right
no matter where you put it on the
diagonal it's maintaining it so why move
the bishop back
no no Bishop a7 it's a prophylactic move
exactly so d4 won't be with a temple and
now or in so now when your opponent
plays like rook e1 or h3 now you don't
cancel you do another prophylactic move
because you don't want to fall into
under this pin so you don't want to you
know what I have to deal with this
position so you make another
prophylactic move and now so what is
White's idea in this position right so
Knight be to Castle this is how most of
my games go yeah so here here and the
night goes to g3 Knight goes to h4 and
then you want to put a knight on f5
bring your queen in attack and in in
return blog gets good center so a few
things to go over again so this position
so a six carries out the threat of
ninety five you don't cancel you don't
cancel if you if your opponent can play
Bishop g5 so Bishop g5 is not dangerous
if you're not cancelled so that's the
important thing to remember so you play
this Bishop a7 move and then h6 and I
know this happens a lot especially in
scholastic just because a lot of my
students they always play this opening
so it's very important for you to
another move order but okay going back
to this position so Bishop c4 Knight f6
does anyone play this move has anyone
faced this wolf yeah so night chief so
you have two options you can either play
the three or ninety five so does anyone
know this opening is actually quite a
dangerous opening so what is works only
move
d 5 so now what's wrong with this
so now white sacrifices it's a long-term
sacrifice which means you're not going
to immediately win but your position is
going to be good so Queen f3 double
attack so if you go back I'm just going
to win upon so you have to come out so I
pin you again then I pin your pawn in
the next move I'm going to play d4 let's
say you defend I can't play d4 Queen
comes out am I going too fast now you
should buy for now your PIN in every way
your kings in the center so I'm down
apiece but I have good compensation
because of your king so if you're going
to play this opening with black remember
if you want to avoid 95 just play Bishop
c5 first and then you never have to
worry about 95 because let's say castle
here this move is silly because you just
castle and this is just a waste of a
move the knight doesn't want to be here
you can chase it away the next move this
exchange is only good for black because
why are two pieces better here then I'm
broke well okay I mean point wise is the
same right six point four six one so why
is Wyatt a better here in some position
broken upon are much better than two
pieces but here it's not the case right
so why it doesn't have any developed
pieces also we're still in the middle
game and the position is closed so the
rooks are pretty useless and then the
middle game would play with our minor
pieces so next well I'm going to play d6
it's not and then my bishop can come out
with a temple once my bishop comes out
my queen comes out the rook will come on
an open file so here minor pieces are
more active and they're going to be more
dangerous than this rooks
because this rooks are not going to
become useful until much later in the
game so we don't want to do this if you
really don't want to have to deal with
this Knight g5 move just play your
Bishop c5 but if you do like to play or
you face this move again two options
either play the three
your pawn play calm or 95 I play 95 a
couple of times actually it's strange
opening so what to do with black here so
95 usually we don't put the knight on
the edge of the board why is it okay
here and why are Knights on the edge of
the board bed right because they're not
bishops you can put a bishop on the edge
of the board
you can put let's say the bishop on this
diagonal then it can suck the whole
diagonal but the knight can do that it
only attacks what immediately around it
so don't do that
but why is it okay to do it here yeah
right again it's a temple move so we're
gaining moves so White has to check
again temple move we block and there are
two moves here for white Bishop d3 or
Bishop e2 I played we should be three
several times it's it's a
strange-looking move I know it doesn't
really make sense but the idea is to
develop the bishop here and black is
down the pond but black is ahead in
development he has better center so you
can say it's there's compensation for
black I mean it's a playable position
I'm not going to say it's good for a
white or it's good for black it's just
whoever plays better they'll play the
position better which is how we play
chess anyways so you can play it for
either side I want to played it for
white but sometimes when I play for
white I feel you know like I felt
uncomfortable because I feel like my
opponent's plays very easy okay so going
back to this h6 move so I played the
form takes takes takes so why is this
bad we can also look at it in this
position the Scotch which a lot of
people also play why don't we take this
knight now
okay yeah
so but usually we don't like to take our
queen out Orlean opening you don't
really use a tempo but why is it okay to
have the queen out now right because
there is no way to attack the Queen the
only way to attack the queen is c-5 why
is this a bad move it's protected it's a
long term bad move because what are you
doing to your pawns yeah you're
weakening your pawns because after I
move my queen let's say even if I move
it all the way back what kind of a pun
is this one backward so it's a backwards
pawn yeah that's an isolated phone it's
an isolated pawn yeah it cannot be
defended by any other pawn it has a pawn
next to it on the same color okay that's
not a good explanation but the reason
this is an isolated point is because
there is no pawn protecting it and the
pawn that's next to it is on the same
color as the pawn so these six is on the
dark square and upon next to it is the C
pawn which is also in the dark square
and your pawn cannot go forward because
this square is attacked so you don't
want to end up with a pawn like this
usually you don't want to have past that
cannot be protected by other pawns
because you have to waste a whole piece
to protect it now you don't want to
waste like a queen or even a bishop to
protect pawn because I mean it's such a
low value piece so c5 is a temple move
but here it's not worth it because
you're creating a long-term weakness and
your pawn structure weaknesses are long
term because pawn structures are they
don't really change because you played
c5 to c5 pawn is not going back no so we
don't do this so usually we don't take
out our Queen because it gets attacked
here it's not going to get attacked so
it's good but okay so if we throw it
Bishop c4 h6 so we
this moves Bishop c4 and h6 is this
better for white or better for black why
and write because I develop the bishop
and all we've done is play h6 I don't
remember so the rest of the game went
something like this
I played here I think nine of six if I
Kris and I it's very very hard for black
to develop I think Queen e7 castle then
I guess my opponent trusted me that he
can take this one say they can take this
one but I think here is very dangerous
because I'm just going to play Bishop d2
threatening rook e1 if you move your
queen next well I'm going to check you
cannot castle so you're going to be you
know it's going to be a very
uncomfortable position and all of this
trouble started with this age six move
because here even if you don't play even
if you don't take my knight
let's say even if you play something
like this now my knight goes to good
square and again I'm ahead in
development actually here I have a
tactic let's say here here okay I can't
find a tactic here right but again queen
h5 you have the double attack but then I
can defend it so universim order so
really most like h6 right because here
you have less control of your center so
you don't want to play eight six in the
position where I show that six you have
control of the center you're close to
castling so everything you're trying to
do in the opening you've achieved so
it's okay to play a move like that so
that's the difference so does anyone
have any questions
no okay another opening that I always
see that's played incorrectly for
Knights
why is this a bad move
there's an opening trick
the people
Knight takes e4 so your opponent can be
clever and stop you from counseling
unfortunately the same thing again I can
do not official castle in two moves and
I've gained two bishops I gain the whole
center so I've given up maybe a few
moves to castle but I've gained so much
that it's totally worth it so you don't
want to run into this if you're playing
with white so but you have to remember
if you play Bishop c5 let's say does
this work now if we reverse the move
order
so now if I take actually sorry I went
too fast in this position
why place d5 so if you take take again I
lost the tempo I move my queen
but better center because I have a pawn
only five two bishops next my pawn will
come to f5 and again so many advantages
so let's say your opponent plays Bishop
c5 your opponent just copies you can you
do this
what can the Naidu
yeah so you lost the piece you have to
be careful so you cannot do this if the
knight only five is attacking something
for example when you play the Italian
and your bishop you're a fine place here
you cannot do this because again you
lose the piece so when you play the four
Knights and this is another common
opening so whoever plays e5 you're
likely to face this at some point the
bishop goes here so what to do with
black
okay so a six let's remember this
position with a six and then let's go
back to the Spanish with a six what's
the difference this position and this
position the Knights are out so what
difference does it make well I mean I'm
not going to give up my bishop so I
don't really care about that it was the
difference in general between putting a
bishop on c4 and a bishop on b5 like
this position in this position like a
lot of differences
and one-third move but you know this one
move makes so much difference in the
position and it changes a lot of the
ideas and we said something I want to
emphasize from early on all these moves
they make a difference every move you
know does something or doesn't do
something so when your opponent plays
wrong when you know your openings you
understand your opening when you
opponent does something wrong you know
why it's wrong because it doesn't you
know they're not following the plan
because you know what you're supposed to
be doing because you know what they're
supposed to be doing okay but what did
it do if you chip something
what is the knight on f3 doing what is
the knight on c6 thing so it's the
bishop on CB 5 thing right so I want to
remove the defender and get the e pawn
so there's a big difference when I play
a bishop on c4 I'm attacking the F pawn
and I put my Bishop won't be 5 at some
point I want to take this night and just
win a central pawn and you know if you
lose a central pawn you're going to be
in a lot of trouble because then t4 is
going to come and then you have no
center so a6 here is actually a move
because takes takes 95 what is blocks
move so how to win the pawn back if you
don't know it try to figure it out Queen
d4 very good double attack so check now
you don't want to move your king so you
have to trade Queens so now your kings
in the center I'm going to cancel next
move I got my two bishops I got the
isolated pawn I'm doubled pawns but you
can't attack them so they're not much of
a weakness if you have a weakness and
your opponent can attack it then it's
not something to really worry about but
let's go back to this position what's
the difference
when the Queen comes and I move my
knight you can no longer take this pawn
now you actually did lose upon so it's
very important for you to play the move
on incorrectly and like I see my own
students always do this incorrectly and
I understand because it's subtle because
here you know you kind of play them
automatically all this moves that's what
I'm saying pay attention to the move so
you know so you can do something a
little trickier so you can take take and
then play twenty four but now I'm going
to castle so you have to take one of my
Knights I suggest you don't take this
one because no matter where the Queen
goes I have discovery they have to take
this guy so now I get another move in so
you have to move your queen again cannot
take so I get all these free moves in
again and now you're again falling
behind so when you're playing the four
Knights the four Knights are already out
you cannot play a six so you have to
copy your opponent actually have to play
Bishop before and now you want to do the
same thing you're going to take they're
not and take their pawn if you're
playing Spanish it's not the Spanish
it's Spanish and you play here which is
normal move and then your opponent plays
here now you actually understand that
you just transfer the transpose into
four Knights
so you cannot play a six so you're no
longer playing the Royal Lopez you're
playing the four Knights so you have to
make this connection in your head and
automatically play a six because here if
I play d3 so what can you play six now
because I protected my pawn I'll win
your phone so it's long key so a six
only works in this position because this
a four pawn is hanging